welcome to dreadnought a third-person
action game where you take the helm of a
massive space vessel you're a mercenary
captain striving to make a name for
yourself in a solar system rife with
conflict you will team up with four
other captains to fight in epic battles
in deep space or inside the atmosphere
of planets to earn fame glory and your
own fleet of ships in order to be an
effective commander you need to know the
fleet inside and out it's not enough to
know your favorite class you've got to
know your enemy and know which ship will
be the most effective in burning them to
the ground
artillery cruisers do their best work at
extreme range delivering deadly salvos
from heavy weapon batteries think of the
artillery Cruiser as a sniper the ship
is big guns strapped onto a quick engine
with almost no heavy armor making it one
of the most vulnerable fliers in the
fleet the artillery Cruiser does its
best work lurking in the outskirts of
battle spotting targets for teammates
and taking out enemy vessels from afar
bulky dreadknots are plumb targets for
artillery cruisers nine of the perfect
shot can be tricky especially when quick
ships like the corvette managed to get
too close for comfort
the Corvette is the smallest most
maneuverable ship in your arsenal dual
front mounted heavy autocannons and the
blink warp drive allow Corvette captains
to make deadly surgical hit-and-run
strikes and wreak havoc on the enemy
Corvettes our scouts running recon and
delivering quick strikes high speed and
the warp jump ability make them perfect
for hunting down pesky artillery
cruisers but Corvettes may fall prey to
the massive firepower of the destroyer
if they aren't careful destroyer class
ships hit the sweet spot between the
massive dreadnought and the agile
Corvette this all-around attack ship is
loaded with firepower making it the
ultimate medium-range hunter ad range
destroyers should stay clear of the
artillery cruisers line of sight a
direct hit can prove devastating in
close-quarter battles destroyers are
tough enough to handle their share of
fire their role is to dart in and cut up
the support craft like the tactical
Cruiser leaving larger more dangerous
ships without defenses
tactical cruisers play a vital support
role they can provide on-the-spot
repairs even to themselves and when
they're caught in a corner or on the
offensive they are more than capable of
causing some damage especially against
wily Corvettes as a mobile repair vessel
the tactical cruiser is the key to the
survival of the fleet and is often seen
in close proximity to other friendlies
enemy destroyers will seek to cut the
tactical cruisers lifeline Cruiser
captains should wait for a destroyer
escort before moving in to support a
dreadnought which brings us to our final
ship the dreadnought it's built for
survivability and for causing massive
damage it's all over when one of these
maneuvers alongside an enemy and
delivers a broadside the dreadnought is
the heaviest class in the fleet they're
hard to take down and their weapons pack
a brutal punch it is foolish to take on
a dreadnought alone and nothing is more
frightening than the sight of a
dreadnought on the horizon launching its
nuclear missile gun for gun the
dreadnought is strong against most ships
but poor maneuverability makes it an
easy target for the long-distance sniper
attacks of artillery cruisers
before you take the helm it is vital to
understand how to handle your ship the
weapon wheel at the center of the screen
acts as a targeting radical but also
provides important information about
ship energy and health ability hot keys
are visible at the top of the screen
once used they will display a countdown
timer for when they can be activated
again
a good captain will learn to time their
attacks switch to the secondary weapon
when a primary is on cooldown activate
your energy generator just before
closing in for an attack to maximize
your damage and leave your opponent in
flames bringing the right ship to bear
at the right time can mean the
difference between victory and utter
defeat remember what you've learned and
you'll be on your way to becoming one of
the most renowned and feared captains in
the solar system